foreign
Scott's weather Scott is in Phoenix hi
Scott welcome to the Ramsey Show
Merry Christmas everyone merry Christmas
how can we help
so I don't do the baby steps I just been
listening to you and I'm debt free I
just have a mortgage and my question is
that I just came into some money which
is about thirty thousand dollars and I
want to invest it in retirement because
I'm hitting 53 and I really don't have
any retirement I have been paying into
my 401k every time I get a raise at work
I've been upbeat my 401. so for four
years I'm at right now at 4 400 a month
going into my 401 but I'd like to take
that 30 000 and put it into something
that would grow quickly
and you know that I would feel confident
about I don't want to spend it I don't
want to you know just go out and blow it
I'm really starting to you know hit that
age I'm like I really do need to think
about retirement you married
yes I am married
um my wife has her retirement through
her work so she's been working on that
every you know she's been at the job for
about 15 years so she's got her
retirement established Okay jump online
at ramsaysolutions.com and find a
smartvester pro in your area open a Roth
for this year in a Roth for next year
and do one for your wife as well so
that's 14 that's 28 000 bucks
okay and put it all in good growth stock
mutual funds across four types growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
International
now can I add to that you know the
following year of extra money the
following year after 24 after 23 you can
in 24. because I just funded 23 and 24
just then
okay because I want to be able to
because I have extra money left over uh
since I'm not in debt anymore I'd like
and I'm I want you to throw that towards
your mortgage
okay yeah I want to get I want to get 15
of your household income going into
retirement throw everything else towards
your mortgage I'm assuming you have an
emergency fund and you already said you
were debt free but the mortgage right
yes I got forty thousand dollars in in
my emergency fund
because I sold the house and I just
purchased this new house about six
months ago
so we were able to sell my old house for
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars I
put some of it into the new house and
then I just paid all our debt off cars
everything
and then I have as I said I got 40 000
left in the emergency fund for anything
good so that's work and then you know
and then I've been doing
500 extra months on the new house yeah
so here's the thing the baby steps tell
us to put 15 of your household income
into retirement we just loaded up a
couple of roths you've already got your
401 and your wife's 401 going so I'm
gonna guess and say you're probably
getting up to that 15 percent or beyond
beyond that anything I can find in my
mortgage I want to get this house paid
off because the two key things that we
find that cause people to be
millionaires uh and it's not long from
now for you you're going to be there
pretty quick is a loaded up retirement
account or retirement accounts and a
paid for mortgage that's right I want to
make sure though that you don't spend
all of that money I mean I want to make
sure that you keep some of it for three
to six months of expenses that's the one
thing I don't want him to it sounded
like once he paid off the debt he had
that that 30 or 40K left and that was
kind of his nest egg so I want to make
sure that he keeps some of that for us
three to six months as well yeah
absolutely if I was confused I thought
you had 40 Grand plus the 30 grand if
you don't then that's a different thing
you need an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses that's baby step
three four is you're gonna put 15 of
your income into retirement between Roth
IRAs 401K for you 401K for your wife add
it all up 50.15 times your annual income
and you need to be there and no more
everything else goes towards that
mortgage let's get that mortgage cleared
uh because that paid for house and uh
you know half a million to a million
dollars in your mutual funds in your
401ks and Roth IRAs is where you're
going to uh that's where you're going to
reach that million dollar net worth and
Beyond of course